it is friday it is our final day of
wayne newton week mr las vegas has given
us an inside look at his career and how
it started and his new show with the
flamingo in fact is where he started and
headlined many decades ago
so now what's next for the international
star here's what he had to say to me in
our one-on-one
it's taken me all these years to get
back to where i started it's a circle
so so what does that mean for you next i
mean it's obvious that you love doing
this
you know i have to say
retirement is that ever going to happen
for you no no no i i don't believe in
retirement for openers
my reason for waking up every morning
and looking forward to going to work
would be the smiles and the happiness
that
little bit even
of happiness that i can bring to people
that
that are trying to escape
the hazards of life well he certainly
does bring a lot of smiles to a lot of
folks so there you have it no retirement
for the man who's graced las vegas
stages for 65 years coming up later in
the show uh he just celebrated his 80th
birthday and he jokes about how that
went down
he's got some ideas on how you might be
able to celebrate your next birthday you
don't want to miss that jumping out of a
plane
that might work it's just an idea all
right we're